[Music]
check
yes yes yes yes
i got a good one for you
okay
and we're gonna explain
boiling water
okay i know it sounds completely do we
planned on scalding someone
no it's just that this it's an
explanation i know i know i just thought
there's stuff going on
that people
need to know they should know
no nobody needs to know what i'm going
to tell you but i think you'll be glad
for having learned it
okay okay will this have anything to do
with a watched pot
and the fact that the contents will
never boil i was such a literal child
that when i heard that
i i tested it
i watched probably i watched it and then
it boiled i said well that's one that
people don't understand once again these
adults lying to me
never trust anybody over 30. i was such
a literal child so anyhow so watch what
happens okay so you have this pot of
water right part of anything but let's
just stick with water okay and
the water is composed of molecules
and all the molecules
are banging against each other
they're not in any kind of structure or
lattice otherwise the water would be
solid all right it would be ice
unstructured banging molecules okay so
now sounds like an orgy go ahead so
in our liquid pot you have these
molecules of water and you can tell me
what the
molecular
form of water is
uh two parts hydrogen one part oxygen
take it h2o h2o you got it okay oh by
the way i've said this before but since
you gave me the answer in that way
okay two parts hydrogen one part oxygen
i'm just trying to sell smart neil no i
was good i don't even know what that
means no because you told it to me that
way let me just slip this in
that in the old days when we used to
launch the space shuttle
okay there's this huge orange tank
right under its belly
okay sitting between two solid rocket
boosters yeah okay okay that orange the
solid rocket booster is solid fuel you
light them they go and you can't
throttle them down they go until they
die and then they part ways and then the
shuttle goes into orbit with the orange
tank
and then
detaches from that and the tank burns up
in the atmosphere okay that orange tank
has liquid fuel in it that you can
throttle up or down
okay
and it has two tanks one of them twice
the size of the other
okay the one that's twice as big has
liquid hydrogen in it
the one that's half the size is liquid
oxygen
and there's a nozzle that combines these
two liquids
if you combine two parts hydrogen to one
part oxygen which is exactly how you
told me how to get a pot of water what
do you get if i combine two parts
hydrogen one part oxygen you get water
well you have water and water viewing
out of the back of the nozzle so now you
got a rocket engine that's
you got fuel now from water you've got
fuel because to make water is highly
exothermic right okay energy is released
and so that orange tank taking the
shuttle into orbit does not pollute the
air at all just adds water to it
okay okay that's first of all that's
genius i'm i'm never it never ceases to
amaze me how smart these nasa people are
that's why it's called rocket science
you ever see this shirt uh you know
there's a rocket going it's not rocking
science well actually it is
it actually is rocket science yeah so
here we are in the in the pot of water
we are not breaking apart the hydrogen
and the oxygen they are bound together
for this entire conversation okay as a
water molecule so
now you turn on the heat this is a great
experiment to get your kids to do i did
it with my kids okay
so
you put on the heat
and get a thermometer and have it read
the temperature of the water
okay and then you write down that
temperature
but the heat is on
okay so come back in one minute
measure the temperature again and you
write down the temperature okay there's
a merk
so we're fahrenheiting this
so
the the water is now 100 degrees and
then it's 110 degrees right you just
keep doing this every minute you see the
water the f
in fahrenheit
stands for freedom
because this is merck merc
we're going to use complicated
fahrenheit units because we're free
that's right
even though we've actually imprisoned
ourselves in the world
with with our own
units of measure for some things
so now we're at 110 degrees 110. you
just keep doing this and get and you
write down what time it is the flame is
staying there and you just keep writing
down the temperature you keep doing 110
120 130 140 150. you can write a plot
you can plot this
on a chart
okay if your kid has had that that much
math yet right you can put temperature
and time and you watch the temperature
go up
okay
you keep doing this and so i had my kids
do it okay it's 190 degrees okay i
wonder how much is it boiling yet no
okay i wonder how high we can get the
temperature so they go back there's 200
degrees is it boiling no i see a few
bubbles but is it boiling no okay 205
206
207
212 is it boiling yes it's boiling you
see a lot of that beginning like a 210
220 okay
go back a minute later what's the
temperature now it's still 212. okay
wait a minute come back in five minutes
what temperature down it's still 212.
oh my gosh
what the hell just happened
we were increasing the temperature of
our flame under this thing
flame
if you add flame to something you're
supposed to increase the temperature
aren't you and that's what was happening
and then the temperature pegged
it didn't get hotter than 212 degrees it
just stayed there and you got the data
to show it
so what's happening that's what i want
to know okay
that's why i'm here neil that was my
question what is happening where does
the heat energy go
it's got to go somewhere so we didn't
dip we didn't hit a heat ceiling we just
reached an energy threshold is that what
no no you're putting too many too many
words in the second word salad there
okay so all i'm saying is what we
observed
okay we are definitely adding we didn't
turn off the heat no
the heat is still going and we saw what
effect that had on the water
right but if we kept adding heat meal
this is my question
why would the temperature not keep going
up if you just keep adding heat because
of a magical thing that goes on in
nature called
phase change
it's called a phase change okay that
sounds very star trek harry potter
i didn't say phaser change
okay phase change
so
the water
is becoming steam
right
that takes energy
okay
in order to turn boiling water at 212
degrees
into steam at 212 degrees
takes energy
gotcha
that'll eat
all that energy
until there's no water left
then you have a pot of steam
well that will blow up the pot because
steam takes up more volume than the
water but if you had a if you had a
vessel a steam capture a seam capture
correct you'll keep heating the water
till it all becomes steam
then the temperature of the steam will
go up and you can continue this exercise
oh
that's pretty cool
okay
that means the steam
carries more energy than you thought
well of course it does that's how you
power everything from locomotives
to hot air balloons that's only
everything you have any air everything
from 100 years ago yeah it's a steampunk
movement
a steampunk baby
all of my crazy contraptions that look
like transformers are powered by steve
okay so actually
the
the reason why most of those machines
work is not because steam is hot oh
really it's just because the volume of
steam is so much greater than the water
so they create what a pressure yeah it's
a pressure thing it creates pressure and
so because the steam wants to get out
it'll go through a nozzle it'll push us
pissed in it'll do whatever that the
locomotive thing so so that's why
but but it's exploiting sort of the
thermodynamics of it i have a volume of
a substance and then i do something to
it to give it much much more volume that
takes energy
okay yes i have to put in energy to turn
that water into steam
so that it has the steam pressure of
what you then needed to give you for the
machine at the risk
of sounding ignorant which is no risk
for me at all okay no risk for me at all
let me ask my risk-free question here
where does the energy come from
in order for that to happen is it coming
from the flame heat that yes
yes so it's yes okay and in power plants
it's coming from coal and in in
hydroelectric plants it's coming from
water pressure
going through turbines so all so
so all of these ways of making energy is
converting energy from one form into
another
so uh oh oh
i see so basically the
whatever this you know you want to call
it the water or whatever
that change is under that it's
undergoing that change
it's actually taking the energy
from the heat and then creating the
change
yes it's taking that energy instead sets
to its molecules get the hell out of
here get out of here at high speed right
okay get the hell out of here so one by
one molecules are leaving the surface of
the water going into another state of
matter
wow the steam state fire's a bad
landlord just
you are all you're evicted get the hell
out
you're all only if you hit a certain
temperature right
yeah it's evicting it all is it that's
correct
by the way by the same token it works
the other way
uh you're a scotch drinker let me hear
your scotch voice every once in a while
i come back here
i would like to play a little song for
you right now it's called a dragon i
dread to wisconsin she left me
okay
all right so chuck
this fact that i just shared with you
enables some very interesting things
it's why
you can boil water in a paper cup
all right
okay okay
and i've done this okay so here's what
you do okay what what absolutely
i just listen
you're the only person i've ever heard
utter these words in my life so
i mean clearly i have been traveling in
the wrong circles
i'm a grown man ain't nobody in my life
ever said to me did you know you can
boil water in a paper cup really no one
ever said that you didn't know about
this i swear i didn't oh my god i listen
i'm oh my god okay i you know i did not
know this okay so you need like forceps
otherwise your hand will get burnt but
so so here's what you need a flame
that's like the size that just is
touching the bottom of the paper cup
okay part of the problems with paper
cups is they have ridges that go beyond
the side of the cup and those will burn
but the cup that's touching the water
tell me the highest temperature that cup
paper can ever get
from the water will it
wouldn't it be
if the water is in it 212 degrees
yes yes
that's the hottest that's the paper can
burst into flame at 212 degrees no no no
it famously burns at what temperature oh
i wouldn't know
451 that's fahrenheit 451. aren't you a
literate person i i didn't know that was
the reason why he named the book that
way i thought it was yes fire
that that's what what are books made of
papers right in the old days that makes
sense right okay
so
if the water is touching the paper
the hottest the paper can ever get is
just the temperature of the water
temperature of water
and you heat the water and it gets and
then it just starts boiling
until the water leaves entirely then
it burns right
that's why it's very hard to completely
incinerate a human body
and proving the saying
we don't need no water
let the mother effort burn
burn mother effort burn i don't know i'm
sorry i i mean i wasn't in that circle
of the day that
happened i'm sorry
[Laughter]
all right see this is how i know you're
saying the people
i love it i love it there there's a
saying
it goes the roof the roof the roof is on
fire and then the response is we don't
need no water
let the mother effort burn
burn mother effort
burn i have never
ever heard that all right well now we're
even different i've never heard of water
boiling in a paper cup and you never
heard that the roof was on fire
so i might do a tick tock uh boiling
water in a paper cup but anyhow point is
point is you've heard about spontaneous
combustion this legendary way people
dissolve into ash yes
you have what is it six quarts
or i don't know what what is the how
much blood we have in our body okay i
have no idea we have liquid in our
whatever whatever we are almost seventy
percent
we have it's almost 70 water between 60
and 70 percent water you cannot
completely burn the body until all that
water leaves right
that's all
it's very simple you cannot
toast bread
until
the heating elements get rid of all the
water on the surface of the bread that's
why most of the time the bread is in the
toaster
it hasn't it doesn't look like it's
cheap it's not toasted yet it's those
last couple of the last minute it says
now i can brown your toast which is why
i burn every damn piece of toast i try
to cook
it's not linear with time
and you can't instantly toast it just by
showing soft fresh bread to to heating
coils it has to get rid of the water
first
then it can raise the temperature
otherwise everything's sticking to 212
degrees first of all this was a great
explainer secondly now i want a sandwich
toasted
of course
i'm not an animal all right
that's all we got chuck all right gotta
call that one quits okay that was the
beginning middle and end of boiling
water and of course for the euro
audience 212 degrees fahrenheit
100 degrees celsius but you already knew
that this is star talk yet another
explainer video video always good to
have you there chuck always a pleasure
you're the grass tyson here keep looking
[Music]
you